foreign
hit my husband had some legit questions
he's decided that the Mormon church is
not legitimate and it's not true it's
just something about my children of like
they're going to believe anything I tell
them and that really caused a lot of
like self-reflection of just like well
why do I believe it I believe right
[Music]
what up what up what up this is John
with the Dr John deloney show greatest
mental health and relationship and
parenting podcast ever recorded or if
you're watching us on YouTube I mean
easily the best YouTube show ever
uh I think there's 12 billion YouTube
shows so if you're with us thank you so
much for spending your time with us
um if you want to be on the show give me
a buzz
1-844-693-3291-1844-693-3291 and you can
leave a message and Jenna will give you
a call back and please don't forget to
share the episode and leave your five
star reviews if you have two star
reviews
um call your mother-in-law and tell her
she's giving you a two-star performance
so far see how that goes for Christmas
that will be excellent and
uh huge news huge news number one Ben
this weekend was Battle the bands here
at Ramsey Solutions the
parent company I work for and there's
about what 1100 employees here and it's
some of the most talented people on the
planet people everyone comes to
Nashville to make it and then at some
point we all have to get real jobs and
so there's this building full of
incredible drummers and guitarists and
keyboardists and singers and programmers
and all kind of things rappers if you're
be who anyway
we brought the Thunder this week it was
incredible right oh it was Unforgettable
we melted faces exactly
um
it's depressing to say that's the
highlight of 2022 for me oh it's same I
think it's true I've got a family we've
had a great year we sold like made
number one best of all
easily I bought my first house this year
and battle of the bands was better than
that
dude as an outsider I can say it was so
much fun that was fun yeah that was fun
and if you're watching this I'm hoping
to have Sarah put some pictures of it oh
yeah you do so check out YouTube uh the
Youtube my wife uh Sheila showed up and
and for those of you like y'all always
think I'm kidding she's never listened
to a single show she's just like hey you
go do your thing like she just says
perform me John she says it just oogs
her out
um she likes compliant do the dishes
John that's her favorite version of me
and she showed up she came and she just
smiled the whole time and she was like
that's the guy that I married like a
long time ago I remember that guy and my
favorite thing was at the end of the
show everyone was leaving and
um by the way there's like 2 000 people
because everyone's got A plus one it's
just a chaotic Mayhem of a mess it's
just a blast and
um
some people came and they said was it so
fun to be able to cut loose like that
and I S I said listen
that's what my poor wife has to deal
with every week like the the version
you'll see on the podcast is a very
xanaxed out version of myself like I
don't think Xanax but it's a very chill
professional this is his professional
kids anyway and then yesterday
Sunday morning I'm putting my shoes on
and my daughter Josephine who's six
walks in my room
and stares me down for a second and she
says
I will fight you
I didn't know why she said that
but then we fought
I did not fare so well all right let's
go to Christy in San Antonio what's up
Christy
hello how we doing good morning I'm good
sorry I have a little bit of a cold oh
no it's all good
um how are you
I'm good really good just enjoying the
weather finally cooling down here in San
Antonio very cool I was in Houston
yesterday and it was much warmer that is
here in Nashville hopefully you guys
will get some more cool weather coming
I hope so you know 80s is better than
100 so I I can hang with that for a few
months 80s that's like the depth of
winter for San Antonio
so how can I help what's up
all right so I I'm so grateful you were
willing to take our call
um
I love your show and uh so I have a
wonderful amazing husband and we have
three beautiful kids
and uh we met in the Mormon church we
married in the Mormon Church we're very
Mormon
we are very if I had a t-shirt company I
would make a shirt that just said we are
very Mormon
yeah because because hey here's what's
funny I'm not Mormon and I know exactly
what you mean it's so great so good yeah
when people see me you know when I make
friends with people like yeah you had a
Mormon five yeah you know that's me I
guess very cool fortunately or
unfortunately you get to pick there you
go so you were very y'all y'all the gang
is very Mormon yeah
we just yeah we're in it so all right
you're in about
yeah so when covet hit
you know we stopped going to church and
my husband had some legit questions and
so the past couple of years he's been
looking into our history and things like
that and recently he's kind of put a
firm
stop to that meaning he's decided that
the Mormon church is not
it's not legitimate and it's not true
and there's a lot of there's a lot of
uh you know just strange awful things
that happened in our history
embarrassing things sure and I am I
totally understand where he's coming
from
I just have a different perspective than
he does
and so I want to keep going but I'm
willing to work with him and compromise
and go to the Mormon church every other
week then go to another church every
other week like I am willing to do that
and teach our kids open-mindedly and
teach them you know to think for
themselves and kind of come to an
understanding on their own of what their
personal belief Sciences beliefs should
are very personal and it should be a
personal Journey
so I'm willing to do that but we keep on
hitting this wall of
you know he just really has a hard time
with us continuing to go
um there's just a lot of things that you
know they when one parent doesn't really
believe sometimes they say well let's
pray for your parent you know little
things like that
um and he just doesn't want to be
painted as a bad figure and to me that's
something that we have control over as
parents
and we get to decide you know what our
how our children view us and we have to
talk about things that they're they're
taught or that they're here
Etc and we get a voice I think he feels
a little differently sure and so you
know he's having a hard time respecting
my desire to want to keep going
um when he's just had such a hard time
with
um you know his side of things does he
have a personal
experience
that has emerged
uh because of it yeah I mean
let's see down his whole mission
um I don't think he's ever
I don't think he's ever drank the
Kool-Aid okay if that makes sense yeah
totally she's always looked good
everyone be like this is you know this
is kind of weird but maybe I just need
to try a little harder okay kind of
thing I think he's always kind of viewed
it that way I could be wrong what what
do you use
you said he's got very valid questions
very valid
uh yeah concerns always
when you say you have a different
perspective I heard it said this way
once um I have a close friend who's a
just an extraordinary theology professor
and very much an atheist and right we
sat by each other in in church and I
asked him once like why do you still
come and he said something that was
profound he said this is my ethnicity
he said this is my culture this is when
I walk into this building I exhale I
right I feel at home here even though I
don't buy everything that's coming from
the pulpit I still believe in the
positivity and I still believe in
community and I still believe in
stopping every week to remember so he
had had
um really Dove it Dove deep and found uh
a way to get to the to continue the
practices while also having different
thoughts
why do you
feel it's important to continue to go
because here's why where this is
important if ultimately you and your
husband land on different Cosmic beliefs
meaning
there is a truck coming down the highway
and if we don't push our kids out of the
way they're going to get hit by this
truck
yeah if if our kids don't go to this
particular building and are not baptized
in this particular denomination this
particular way and they are going to
spend eternity burning in Hell or
whatever the cosmic punishment is in the
Mormon church
then we have to address that and if the
other person says this is all crazy none
of this is real
now you're going to have a problem if
it's like my buddy if this is simply
this is where I feel comfortable this is
where I feel safe this is all I know and
I'm not interested in blowing up
everything that's a different
conversation because that is we're gonna
practice we're gonna have you see what
I'm saying we can we can be slowly
expand that Circle that's different so
where are you in this conversation
interesting I think some Mormons
probably do think if they their children
don't get baptized then or they don't
get married in the temple then they're
going to you know who knows they're not
they're not gonna make it I don't know
eternally but I do not feel that way and
I've never felt that way okay so so what
is that what does the church get you
true and it's inspired okay so I mean I
just like I love the Book of Mormon I
think it's inspired and I think thoughts
can Inspire men in lots of different
areas but this particular church just
speaks to me and it is my home
absolutely I was raised in it but uh
just the doctrines
um if you take away all the history and
just have the doctrine it makes a lot of
sense
if you take away all those things that
yeah that uh that one coach did oh man
those plays you drop are great
um okay so there's messed up history and
I don't have the answers to that oh
there's dude there's messed up history
in every organization that's ever
existed right let's be honest every
organization yeah yeah so here's the
here's the listener plot twist Brandon's
on the other line do you know this
Christy
uh yeah I think he said that he wanted
to join so okay so I want to make sure
this isn't like a Jerry Springer like
where we like gotcha okay all right
um
I know yeah uh Jenna can you you bring
them both in
Brandon you there
I'm here John what's up man
just I wish this was a Jerry Springer
situation
he's so great you are not the father
Brandon hey so um Christy has walked us
through and you've probably been
listening
um I'd love to hear your side of what's
going on
yeah I mean a lot of what you said is
pretty valid uh telling the story I
think like
you know sometime during covid there's
definitely little uh tension in our
marriage about how we're teaching our
kids because she would you know want to
teach my children things and I for some
reason started to feel kind of
uncomfortable like it was just something
about my children of like they're gonna
believe anything I tell them and that
really caused a lot of like
self-reflection of just like well why do
I believe what I believe right and so
hey hey hold on good parenting for both
of you like good parenting for
understanding both of y'all seem to
understand that hey these kids are
impressionable we need to be intentional
about what we're passing along to them
good for you that's incredible
no thanks
all right so I interrupted you go ahead
no you're fine but yeah
um that just kind of caused a real
questioning thing of like well you know
do I really want to tell my kids this if
I don't really
you know know for sure because it's more
of like I'm a good kid I did whatever my
parents told me you know I didn't really
ever question anything before like yeah
a lot of stuff was weird and that's fine
you know I grew up in an area where
there weren't a lot of people in my face
so like I kind of knew that you know
we're kind of weird in some ways and
that's fine but like
um yeah it just sort of caused this
trickle effect of really questioning
like well what do I believe why do I do
it and I just didn't want to give my
kids like tell them all these things and
give them all this baggage if it wasn't
right right so that's what caused me to
dig into it and uh it's been I'd say the
biggest aspect it's difficult
um you know through that thing is just
I feel differently now and that wasn't
what I signed up for and wanted
um that wasn't the answer I wanted like
this is a very uh inconvenient annoying
thing that is a taxing on a variety of
levels
um but you know at the core of like what
we're saying we're trying to do what's
best for our kids and I think I think
for me the hardest aspect is I really
want to respect you know like what my
wife's talking about of like Meet 50 50
or respect what she's saying but like I
feel like I'm just disrespecting her in
that process of like well yeah she's
telling you all this but this isn't how
it is because of this and that's that's
where I feel like I'm making her out to
be some kind of villain while at the
same time kind of how I was taught how I
was raised in this church of we have
this is what you think this is your
salvation it's completely contradictory
right like they're going to be told that
you know the exact opposite of what I
think and so that's where I just feel a
lot of times just like stuck of like
well how do we navigate this how can I
respect her and her beliefs because I
want to do so while also
not giving them things that they don't
necessarily need to go down just for uh
difficult reasons if that makes sense
absolutely all right
um since both of you are on the phone
this is this is rare for me I love this
because I can actually have both of you
on here
um
I want to throw two grenades into the
middle of the couch y'all are sitting on
and let me know if I'm off okay
here's grenade number one Brandon I
don't think you've believed for a long
long time true or false
foreign
it was like it was like I was like
forcing myself to so I mean there's
definitely some validity into what
you're saying but like I never
questioned it like I just kept thinking
why I don't feel this way is because I'm
not following things correctly so yeah
you're not good enough yeah yeah
very long time and the reason I didn't
have like a strong confirmation of that
is because I just guess I wasn't trying
enough
okay but no that's a fair grenade but
like it's not yeah it's not exactly like
that to put to an extent sure so when
people lose their faith or when they
deconstruct it or they begin to pull
apart what they've been told their whole
lives or like you mentioned I just never
questioned it I kind of rolled my eyes
that I did what was the I did the next
thing in front of me
um and by the way this happens with
um
some people find themselves two kids
into a marriage at seven years old and
like what am I doing I I just did the
next thing in front of me some people do
find that professionally and they find
themselves an associate vice president
at a company they don't care at all
about in a job but they hate like so
faith is is an integral part of us right
and by the way I I believe the David
Foster Wallace there's no such thing as
an atheist you worship something whether
it's science or a CrossFit or some sort
of deity you you worship we all
everybody worships something your diet
whatever it is so
it can often feel
um deceptive
like one of y'all like you lied to me or
you're not who I thought I married or if
you really go back and say
um you know I don't think I ever really
bought into this I just did it because I
was a good compliant kid
but I don't ever believe in fill in the
blank
it's easy for Christy to then go
well who did I attach my wagon to right
like I signed up for something that you
weren't right so there could be this
this picture of dishonesty so before we
go further I want to make sure both of
y'all are on the same page it doesn't
sound like there's anybody tricked
anybody or bait and switched anybody or
we both on all everybody on the same
page on that one
yeah yeah this is a it's a legitimate
I'm growing right which is a which is a
challenge that all marriages face
um
all right so
here's the
here's the second grenade
Brandon
I would be willing to bet and again I
love it when I'm wrong so tell me I'm
wrong
that all this focus on your kids
is an easy place to put marital tension
like we've got to do this for the kids
we got to fix this for the kids we got
to get the right answers for the kids we
got to be consistent for the kids lets
us avoid looking across the table at the
woman or man that we love and say
like I'm losing respect for you I can't
imagine how you could believe this
you're not as smart as I thought you
were like really deep seated challenging
questions am I right or am I off
um
yes
so more or less like we're putting
Children First and marriage second and
because of that I'm I'm thinking less of
my wife is that the question
no I'm um
spending a lot of energy worrying about
the kids allows you to avoid the person
sitting in front of you
I mean I think there's a little bit of
that like when you're talking about like
how can you think that but like I I
really I think I'd say the arguments
turned into a little bit of us more than
the kids in some ways so I Kristen what
do you think or Christy what do you
think
I want to say ding ding ding ding ding
ding yeah okay I think I I do I think
that and honestly I think at the core of
why we're stuck because I do feel like I
it doesn't matter what I decide we're
stuck because Brendan has lost respect
for me because I'm reading the same
material as him and I'm coming up with
different answers
and he thinks my answers mean that I am
brainwashed
um and so if I go all the way out
I can't I I'm lying to my children
because I don't
I don't believe that I don't believe the
church's fault
um if I stay partially in and allow
Brendan Brandon to be himself then
um teach his things as well as me and we
kind of go forward together with
different beliefs but we show respect I
feel like I'm not going to get the same
respect that I can give him
what do you think about it
I I didn't what was what was the
question I'm sorry yeah what do you
think about that
yeah no I I understand that
um yeah I think those those feelings and
and that's part of uh what we're
struggling with is just coming up with a
good answer for that and it sounds like
a lot of that comes on me okay
so a very common path
um and it's a it's kind of a buzzword
right now deconstruction my friend
Justin McRoberts is a um doing some
extraordinary coaching work with folks
who are quote unquote deconstructing
their faith whatever that looks like
he's awesome he's a great thinker along
those lines
um
and if you go back to scripture actually
and I don't want to be a preachy but I
think Jesus was the first one that that
talks about deconstruction you've heard
it was said this way but I tell you this
right so you thought it was this way I'm
telling you it looks like this right and
that's all throughout scripture
um
part of the deconstruction process is
becoming untethered and to what you know
to your routines to the cosmos and then
you have this season of Shame what an
idiot I was and then there's a season of
anger I got pissed off at my parents at
the church and then it's easy to when we
find feel ashamed and we feel angry
one of the great soothing Band-Aids over
shame and anger is to blame somebody to
go after him
and we start going to war with our
heritage with the people who did Evil
things which every group on planet Earth
has evil people in their past we start
getting down that road and then after we
feel some superiority of blame
we feel intellectually Superior
I I feel this way because I'm smarter
than you and you're dumb
and that's where relationships get in a
mess
when somebody starts looking down at the
word the the word Christy said I feel
disrespected
um or I feel like he's losing you're
losing respect in her that's where I
want to spend most of your focus
here's the deal with your kids one of
the greatest gifts you can give your
kids is to acknowledge openly and
honestly here's the adventure that I'm
on
um I think uh four of the greatest words
in the English language for a parent to
a child is the words I changed my mind
I used to believe this and now I believe
this and in a year or two I may believe
something a little bit different and
here's where I'm headed and here's why
I'm headed that way so this the
obsession or the Panic about having the
right answer to give our kids or we're
going to screw them up make no mistake
you're going to give them baggage dude
what you want to do is to be able to
teach them model for them when you have
baggage regardless of how it got there
whether it's a coach or a teacher or a
girlfriend that dumps you or some mean
boy or somebody who abuses you or
whatever life will give you bricks in
your backpack you'll get baggage
this is what it looks like to be in
relationship with somebody and both of
y'all figure that out so in my house my
wife and I both identify as Christian we
both go to the same church we have
radically different beliefs on certain
topics certain issues
like she she my wife will roll her eyes
when I try to explain something and
um I'm not I don't I can't roll my eyes
that well but I'll be like I just think
you're missing the boat on this and so
we have this a similar value structure
but we have very different beliefs in
our house and my friends who identify in
the city who go to the same church as me
we have very different beliefs we have
very different beliefs on how I've Got
Friends that cannot believe I work where
I work
I've got one friend and I love her to
death and she's like every time I listen
to your podcast I just want to yell at
you because you're so wrong on all these
things right so that's just like that to
me I don't there's not a disrespect
there it would be disrespectful if they
weren't honest with me
um so here's my concern Brandon
that you are taking a moral Superior
High Ground
and that's a dangerous place to be do
you feel yourself going there and I only
say that because I've been there too
like I look at other people like you're
dumb for not believing X Y and Z right
uh yeah sure
is there a way to
model for your kids
um this is what changing beliefs look
like I was taught this as a kid as I've
gotten older
um I don't believe this anymore here are
some really great things that I took
from this though I do think a weekly
practice is good I do think Community is
good I do think singing is good is there
a way to find the good or is it just
scorched Earth for you
yeah I mean I think there is a way to to
find the good in it I mean because more
than anything it matters to Christy so I
you know want to support her in that and
and you know not have her disaband and
something just because I I no longer
think that way I think like my struggle
is
I I just reflect back on my own life and
why I think the way I do and the
teachings that are taught and it's like
man I just feel there's a lot of harm
and so that it I I gotta I gotta find a
way to know that you know the parental
view is going to have more of a sway
than what teachers and leaders are
teaching them right but well in in
Christy this is where it's really
important he said an important word I
think this is harming our kids
and
belief in a higher power belief in love
belief in Salvation belief in value and
worth
um there's no harm there
belief certain things being communicated
um that harm your kids
that's where you Chris you have to sit
down and say I think our kids are being
hurt or you all got to find some sort of
common value there or some sort of
common language there
um
here's what I really want you to spend
your energy moving forward Less on
worrying about the kids
they are going to pick up the marital
tension they're gonna pick up Brandon
when y'all get ready for church the
huffing and puffing and the eye rolling
and the
they're gonna pick up way more on that
than they are
some Sunday school teacher telling them
some weird thing about some weird
whatever
they're gonna pick way more up Christy
sitting there in church by herself or
not going and her huffing and puffing
around the house they're gonna you see
what I'm saying they're gonna absorb
that tension much more than being open
about
here's where we're going here's why
we're doing this I used to believe this
I was taught this I don't really agree
with this I believe this and they're
going to tell you this today
um I don't I don't believe that I
believe this and at some point you all
have a conversation about here's where
we're gonna end up
um there is no smooth simple way forward
the only path you'll have forward is to
agree that we're gonna do this together
and that if anybody feels morally
Superior anybody feels I've got to call
a timeout that you feel empowered to do
that and it's real easy to suddenly not
be able to do that anymore
is that fair
yeah so when you say a timeout meaning
like
when some when I you know when the
respect isn't fully there we just call
it time out on the discussion and circle
back well it's you Christy being able to
say I feel like you think I'm stupid
right now
yeah or Brandon you're back on your high
horse again I know
I know that they're gonna say this and I
disagree
um and Brandon you giving her permission
right she gets to decide when she's
disrespected and and vice versa you get
to decide hey
this this is going to harm our kids I'm
telling you I've experienced harm from
these messages or this particular
message it scares me to put our kids
back in that and Christy you gotta hear
that
okay right and
merging cultures is hard changing Minds
is hard changing beliefs is hard
it works best when we can do this
together and what I don't want to see
you as you all lose your marriage over
this
are you both in yeah
oh yeah
yeah
Christy's like oh yeah Brandon's like I
mean
I'm messing with you dude I'm messing
with you
um Brandon let me ask you one more quick
question are you out completely of all
Faith are you done with it
no no it's no it's uh I mean there's
obviously like multi-levels of
deconstructing what's going on because
sure once you feel you've kind of been
LED astray it's like well now do I want
to explore my faith in Jesus my faith in
Christianity my faith in the Bible and
like I'm trying to like just pull the
brakes on that really hard because that
stuff does matter to me and it's been
forming for me and important and I want
my children to have that how are you how
are you how are you doing your
do you have people walking alongside you
in this are you watching a lot of
YouTube
that's that's a that's a great question
uh YouTube guy uh I'm definitely like
the only person I know who doesn't watch
YouTube on a regular basis good for you
um well thank you I guess
um a lot of it comes from like the
initial aspects of it there's like for
example this has obviously probably been
a pretty common issue with numerous
faiths is people questioning stuff and
whatever
um and so I tried to stay pretty basic
on far as far as sort of like initial
research on it uh like the church itself
has a link on their website of
troubling things about their past and so
in this whole process like I I know like
in the back of uh everyone's mind mine
included it's like is this always what I
wanted like have I always doubted but
like I really like in this process tried
really hard to stay where I am because
you know trust me I'd rather be doing
something else than having this
conversation like a lot of men but
um as I go through and like look at
stuff like I was looking like through
sources through the church and then I'd
well I think that I was never taught
that and then I'd like click on all the
source material which would link through
you know deep uh how would I call it
there's like Archives of all kinds of
information of posts and sure I would
read like the whole thing and I just
finding more stuff and then just being
like am I in a Netflix documentary like
what is going on okay so
I'd read all these apologist books like
I read one book I tried it was hundreds
of pages and I got like 13 hours through
the audiobook and it just like kept
opening up more and more stuff it was
like it really felt like I was watching
like that Netflix documentary it's like
wait am I in this and so that's that's
really like how how this is kind of
formed and started and like yeah now
there's every now and then there's
other things I come across or things
that pop up that I I'm more open to
reading where in the past I was taught
oh this person's view I've like heard
the name and they're the devil or
whatever right okay here's your here's
your here's your here's your homework
okay yeah
um
this weekend yesterday I flew to Texas
for a funeral did a day day trip and um
one of my family members passed away it
was a hard day and
the the small little chapel was packed
and I heard stories about my family that
I didn't know
and I saw family members I haven't seen
it a long time and I was like whoa
and I learned things and heard things
and saw things
and if I'd read that in a book
it would have been a very it would have
been very easy to de-personalize it
to see it in black and white
and hearing these stories in the context
of everybody getting together
in communion and community and love and
grief and sadness and we laughed like
crazy
and we shared a meal together it
provided a new context
so here's your here's your homework
um I want you to stop going down the the
information rabbit holes
that stuff's really important
but I want you to spend some time
talking with people who've walked away
from their faith
talking people in the Christian faith or
in the Mormon fact what I don't care who
talk to wise people
um and stop trying to absorb all of this
by yourself with data
um
and we have completely in my opinion
ruined Faith with info we've just gone
down a rabbit hole of data and info and
this and that and we've we've completely
lost the communal aspect to this the
wisdom nature of the of the conversation
across all different faiths
so I want you to put down the reading
for a bit put down the podcast for a bit
put down the documentaries for a bit and
I want you to spend a season talking
with people
listening saying hey I'm about I think
I've lost everything
and I think I'm I'm I feel like I'm
hurting my wife I feel like I'm hurting
my kids I don't want to I want to love
them but I can't keep doing this anymore
and spend some season and wise counsel
and let's start there and Christy and
Brandon both of you the a thanks for
calling and being open I know this is
very very hard and by the way this is
the United States right now homes are
dividing over do we go to church I'm not
going to that church anymore this church
I don't believe in anymore I don't
believe in any of it anymore I'm at the
church of vegan whatever or the Church
of CrossFit or the Church of Starbucks
or whatever
we're seeing it just shift in in our
country and I want people to Circle back
to the core relationship first
who are we who do we believe what do we
believe why do we believe it
what practices back up that belief how
do we live those practices out
throughout the week what are we going to
pass along to our kids
all of those things are critical and
important
but let's start with a central core
Mission we're going to keep our marriage
strong and I promise to
um honor you you promise to honor me I'm
gonna do the best I can to meet your
needs and I'm going to do the best I can
I want you to do the best you can to
meet my needs and I won't keep secrets
I'm gonna tell the truth and I'm not
gonna think I'm better than yours
morally or intellectually Superior to
you
and also when I say hey this scares me
this hurts I need you to listen to me
we're going to start there
and then we're going to surround
ourselves with wise counsel there are 5
10 15 20 years ahead of us on this
deconstruction Journey
let's go that route
let's go that route and my promise is
over time the conversation will shift
from a matter of Doctrine and a matter
of this and that to a matter of peace
and connectivity and all sudden the the
whole conversation about faith opens up
in a way that is so much bigger than any
of us could have ever imagined thank you
all for being brave and having this
conversation grateful for you we'll be
right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement and MLS ID 1591
nmlsconsumeraccess.org Equal Housing
lender 1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100
Brentwood Tennessee 37027 programs are
for select loan types only and not
available in all states or locations
all right let's go to Trey in H-Town
what's up Trey
what's going on dog good morning how are
you I'm excellent my brother how are you
I'm doing well I'm doing well and I'm
honored that you're uh that you're
taking my call and I can't thank you
enough for all the guidance and help
you've provided not only for myself but
the rest of your listeners as well you
got it my man what's up dude
my uh my question to you is do you have
any advice or guidance on how to help a
loved one while they're experiencing
Panic slash anxiety attack when you're
with them during that vulnerable time
you should call my wife dude she had to
sit with me when I was a mess man
um tell me what's going on
well uh my girlfriend she's uh she's had
a couple she averages a couple a week
um and some are minor but some are
pretty major
um almost to the point of some some sort
of I don't want to say paralysis but the
hands cramp feet cramp up lock up and
then her body just gets exhausted
um you know it's hurting sleep it's you
know doing it's it's the whole gamut of
things so you know I've experienced a
few myself
um and I know what it feels like I don't
wish that upon anybody I just I just
feel pretty helpless to be honest with
you so I'm just seeing if I could seek
your advice and if you have any thoughts
on that have you I mean three a week is
a lot she needs to go seek medical
attention if she hasn't already if she's
seen a doctor
uh yes I've actually helped her get into
a therapist as far as a doctor goes
um I haven't I'm not sure if she's gone
that route yet but I can definitely
touch base with her yeah
um that's a lot
uh that there's a lot going on there
um
so real quick panic attack is it comes
out of nowhere it's sudden right you're
driving and all of a sudden it's this is
it I'm having the big heart attack and
I'm out
um is what it feels like and anxiety
attacks are they're slow builds
generally right they build and build and
build build it's like being an advice
until finally it you just burst right
like if you took a Diet Coke and just
put it in a vise and squeezed it until
it finally exploded right
um
what's the root of her panic and her
anxiety
especially doc she uh she unfortunately
lost her niece unexpectedly a couple
months ago okay um it was a it was a
traumatic deal
um it was it was very sad it even
affected me some to some degree to be
honest with you
um so I don't know that uh that that
that was dealt with
um and then I had a couple of Health
scares myself you know about a month
after that so it kind of shifted the
um the priority or the focus from her
niece to myself
um and then you know getting through
what I went through the what I would
call the gamut of doctor visits and all
that good stuff
um then all of my results came back good
and then I think it just kind of is
reopening that wound that's that's my
personal opinion I'm not a doctor
but that's kind of what I'm what I'm
thinking all right
um one of my favorite questions to ask
guys who have are
um
who are in a romantic relationship with
somebody
um what's going on is I want to get to
how you answer the question and you
answered exactly how I would have
answered it exactly how it answered it
and I'm going to tell you that my guess
is you are possibly contributing to this
which is awesome because that means you
can be of
um part of the solution is that cool
yes sir please
um so she your your her niece died
suddenly a few months ago how many
months ago
uh the end of July okay so very recently
yes sir okay the phrase you used and you
may have just been spouting it out but I
want you to imprint this on your heart
okay the phrase she hadn't dealt with
that
um this will be something that's
felt that that ricochets through her for
years
so this isn't like hey the check engine
light came on and you need to go get the
oil changed and you just never you went
and got the oil that's not what this is
this is um probably her brother or
sister right lost a child
she had an identity as an aunt she had
an identity as
um she was gonna like this is something
she's thought through for years and
years and years and this little child
suddenly passes away in a traumatic
fashion I mean you see what I'm saying
so this is something that is now altered
there's a before and after with her
and the more as the chief person in her
life right the the guy she leans on
the more you try to fix that or solve
that
the more it compresses her ability to ex
to feel it
and that shoots kind of comes out of her
body in all sorts of crazy ways like
locking it down or trying to fight
something or trying to run from
something and though you've heard the
old fight or flight right yes see what
I'm saying so what she's got to do she's
gotta I mean she's she's gonna see a
counselor I don't even like the words I
don't something about your relational
Dynamic I I went and found her a
counselor she's got to be willing to go
get well
you see what I'm saying she's gonna have
to walk through that that she's got to
walk through hell and you can be with
her but she's got to make that walk and
the more you
um make the calls for her make sure she
goes to all the appointments check in
there's this strange reinforced
helplessness that that begins to cycle
through see what I'm saying yes sir and
you love her don't you
yes sir and you want to do everything
you can to help
absolutely and it's so hard when the
have you ever been in the weight room
are you a weightlifter
uh yes or played college football so
very familiar okay you understand this
like the spotter can really help
but the the less the spotter touches the
bar on on the bench press the stronger
that guy's gonna get
right yes sir and so you want you don't
want to see your person that you love
crushed by this barbell and so it's easy
to jump in there early help pick that
bar up everybody feels like they're
winning I got the bar up I'm tired you
got to help
but nobody's getting stronger
see what I'm saying yes sir so
um I want you to not think of her as
something to fix she's not broken her
body's doing exactly what it should be
which is it has freaked out and then you
got sick what happened with you man
uh I had a uh I don't remember the
doctor term but I fell over hit I
blacked out hit my head
um and then woke up in a pool of blood
and then went through the whole gamut of
doctors and did all the the CT scans
brain scans harp scan all that good
stuff
um haven't even passed that many tests
in school to be honest with you
um but uh but yeah there was just a uh
it was pretty it was pretty up and down
for the for the three weeks following
the uh or the month and a half ball on
her niece passing away so imagine her
like let's take her cognitive
functioning for a second let's put that
aside
her body has just experienced a
traumatic loss of her niece
and suddenly the person that she sees
the rest of her life with
Falls over and hits his face on the
ground and you know as well as I do all
those the doctors are like well it could
be brain cancer and it could I mean
that's where they start right and it
could be that you're having an aneurys
they they go to the worst case scenario
and work backwards
um they don't often start with blood
sugar or fainting or exhausted or hadn't
eaten they start with end of times
her body has already put a GPS pin in
that trauma everything can go away at
any second
yes sir and then 60 days later boom the
man that she loves might be going away
too
like I it doesn't surprise me one bit
that her body is rattling through time
and space right now
so whenever I hear somebody who's
struggling with anxiety
um by the way like
so I tell you to tell you she's not
broken she's not dysfunctional she's not
falling apart
what she needs is healing not fixing and
those are two radically different words
fixing is we've got to turn a wrench I
gotta fix your meds I gotta adjust this
up a little bit
um I need to put your bone back in like
your shoulder back in the socket healing
is
I'm gonna come over
and I'm just gonna sit there and hold
your hand
and we're gonna write a letter to that
little niece together
you see what I'm saying
yeah sure and she's going to be a
tearful puddly mess
and you're not going to say all right
all right stop crying and you're not
going to say any sort of you need twos
or you should none of that language
yeah sure you're just gonna put your
hand on the side of her face and you're
gonna hold her
yes sir see what I'm saying and we're
gonna do this over and over again and
then we're gonna go for a walk
absolutely and what we're doing is
whenever somebody tells me that they're
anxious they're struggling with anxiety
here's the three places I go connection
um safety are you safe are you being
abused are you in a toxic work
environment and autonomy do you have
control over what happens next and right
now autonomy has been completely
stripped from her
one almost two people who she loves just
poof we're almost gone one of them was
gone the other one almost was gone her
body is telling her you have no control
over anything
the second one is it's scary to find
yourself completely alone to have your
brother or sister lose a child and you
don't know what to say you know what to
do
and the third one is everyone starts
trying to fix you
right and your body gets disconnected
when everyone's treating you like a
widget like a like a dysfunctional
lawnmower or a broken lawnmower
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to reintroduce connection back
into this relationship which means and
you're going to think what are you
talking about dude I talk to her all the
time we text all the time I show up all
the time
what you're doing is you're giving her
information you're not connecting with
her
yes sir okay so here's your homework are
you ready
yes sir we're going to today when we get
off the phone I want you to spend some
time writing her a letter telling her
how much you love her
telling her you're not going anywhere
man
telling her that you are going to stop
trying to fix her
you're going to start being with her
and then I want you to read that letter
to her face
number two
I want you to ask her
not show up and tell her ask her
what do you need today
what do you need this week and she might
say I don't know I don't know
and you can say well I'm gonna come over
unless you told me not to
I'ma come over I'm just gonna sit with
you
we can watch whatever you want to watch
read what you want to read do whatever
sing whatever you want to say I'm just
gonna sit with you
I'm not gonna try to put the moves on
you I'm not gonna I'm just gonna come
sit with you
and here's what you do when you show up
her body will do this
oh
and when you ask her hey what do you
need
you're going to slowly reintroduce
autonomy to her she's gonna get some
little bit of control back on the only
thing on the planet she can't control
which is her thoughts and her actions
and she can speak her needs out loud and
you can say got it I'm on it
we're gonna stop parachuting in to solve
all of her problems and we're going to
hold her hand while she stands up
and my my we're Argan also she needs to
go see a doctor and uh make sure get
some make sure her heart's working good
make sure she's okay but it doesn't
surprise me at all
um she needs to keep going to her
counselor
and I I'm willing to bet if y'all spend
some time
really grieving the loss of this little
one
you being honest about how scared you
were
you thought man this could be really
scary I might lose her be honest with
her tell her those words Trey I know
it's not a cool Houston guy thing to say
but tell her I was scared
I thought you were gonna lose me and I
don't want to lose you
now we're not avoid we're not avoiding
the hard stuff
we're getting right in the middle of the
grief and we're gonna sit in it we're
gonna own it and we're gonna find out
over the next two months three months
six months
is suddenly the light comes back on and
her body goes oh you're connected you're
safe you're driving again
stop with the anxiety stop with the
panic
so let's start there
she is really really lucky to have you
my man I'm grateful for you we'll be
right back
hey guys deloney here and I've got a
word from our sponsor whoop if you've
listened to the show for any length of
time you know I'm a major nerd about
Fitness sleep mental health and building
healthier life habits and let's just say
this whoop makes my nerd heart so happy
one reason I love whoop is that it's not
like all the other fitness trackers that
mix in a watch in laser lights and
smiley faces and a million notifications
and reminders that you you need to get
your steps in no whoop is a fitness
wearable that actually looks cool and
it's comfortable and it gives you data
that really matters it breaks down your
recovery your sleep and your daily
strain into a format that's easy to
interpret and some days I wake up in the
green and this tells me that I'm ready
to go attack the day and other days I
wake up in the red and I know that I
gotta take it easy and I can look back
in time and see how I got there if
you're working to be intentional and
build healthier habits whoop can help
you get there start keeping an eye on
your health and wellness at a deeper
level go to whoop dot com that's
w-h-o-oop.com and use promo code deloni
to get 10 off your order today
all right we're back let's take one more
let's go to Erica in Nacogdoches this is
all Texas show what's up Erica
hi Dr John how are you I'm good what are
you doing
yeah I stepped outside of my office for
a bit to take this call so very cool so
what's up
all right so there is
amen I know through church we do not go
to the same congregation but we're in
the same denomination we live about an
hour apart from each other okay and I
have through knowing him through church
functions and just knowing them about a
year and a half have developed feelings
for this person oh oh
I know all the cooties I know is he
handsome
I think so
that's what my wife says when people
like oh is he good looking she's like I
think so good job Erica good job all
right so you've developed feelings for
him okay and so what do you like are you
in or what
I told him about two weeks ago how I
actually feel yes way to go he seemed
very shocked he seemed to have no idea
okay and he's like what do you mean me
I'm weird I'm strange I'm not feeling
worthy what are you talking about and I
just play it all out there I'm honest
with him I had I told him I had to be
honest with you
know even if it's one-sided I felt that
you deserved to know that this was the
dynamic that I'm coming at this from
and I have not heard from him in two
weeks
it is normal for me not to hear from him
for a couple weeks at a time because of
his work and other Church commitments he
has
so it's not the not hearing from him
that
is worrying me I'm just wondering where
is the balance between
I need my answers on how you feel so I
need to either connect or move on versus
your boundaries your schedule your roles
as a man in your church Community like
where's that line and that boundary of
both of us getting what we need out of
this well unless he's put that that
unless he's put that boundary out there
it doesn't exist you're imagining that
boundary and it provides you some amount
of safety because you laid it all out
there and dude I'm proud of you how old
are you
30. dude I'm so proud of you how old is
this dude
53. Dang Gina 53.
yeah dude he probably was like uh what
um yeah like has he ever been married uh
no he has never been married he's the
one that was like if I can tell within a
few dates that it's not going to be
marriage potential I'm not going to
waste my time what a knucklehead
you know who says that 53 year old
single idiots good grief
um listen
I anyway I had that same idea and if I'd
kept to it I still would be single
because I can find something anyway so
here's the deal I'm gonna give him the
benefit of the doubt okay I never met
him I don't know him but I am feeling
optimistic today okay
okay I think
with all of my heart this is a skills
issue
and if he was my friend
I would be razzing him like crazy you're
telling me a beautiful 30 year old woman
just walked up to you and said I've got
feelings for you
um and you just
got back in your truck and drove off
like what's the matter with you know I
mean I would be giving him a hard time
but
I want to honor the fact that this
probably hasn't happened a lot in his
life is that fair
yeah that'd be fair to say and he
probably doesn't know what to do next
and he's probably terrified of these
scary little things inside of him called
feelings
right and that's why I wanted to respect
to like give him the time to process
what I do no you laid a grenade in his
house and you're worried about whether
it went off yes it went off
so
until he sets up a boundary
I would I would have already I mean if I
had the same conversation you did if I
found myself a nice 53 year old woman
and I that's just too weird I'm married
um I was trying to go with it but it
just sounded just was going to get off
the rails
um it you laid it out there
very fair for you to call him back and
say hey we're getting coffee
and we're getting coffee on Friday or
Saturday and then you sit down with them
and say hey I told you I liked you and
you just say anything for two weeks
what's what's what are you thinking what
are you feeling
and if he says well okay I don't have I
I don't you don't you say no I am a
grown woman and I get to like who I like
I like you
I would like you to ask me on a date
or because it's the 21st century you
could say I'm asking you on a date
and literally what you're doing is
you're walking up to his perceived
boundary and you are knocking on it and
you're saying can I come in
and if you do this
he might say no
because all relationship is a risk
I think he would be making a terrible
choice but he might say no
what do you think if you did that what
do you think he would say
I mean I would love to Hope he'd say yes
but he's one of those that you know he's
he's such a sweetheart that in order to
not upset somebody he might do something
that's out of his comfort zone you man
I don't want him to do that I don't I
want him to be honest with you I'd
rather get an honest no then I'm too
sweet to tell you no yes I know but you
hear what you're doing Erica well this
is a whole other phone call
you are already setting up the seeds for
where he can't be successful
because he's going to say sure
and your first response is going to be
you don't have to and then he's going to
start doubting himself
if you don't want to do this don't just
do it to make me happy and he's going to
be like uh I don't I thought you uh okay
see what I'm saying
yeah you are worth going all in
and if it doesn't work if he looks at
you and says honey you're just too young
or I just don't have feelings for you or
I'm just an old man and I just want to
be single
it will hurt like bloody hell
but if he says I'm in
Erica it'll be awesome
I completely agree all of our friends
are already trying to sail the ship
gross gross gross growth but you see
what I'm saying
this only works if you walk over there
and you believe I am worth being in
relationship I'm freaking Erica
and
I like you and I get to like whoever I
want to like
and so I like you and I put it out there
and then you just did whatever you do I
don't know what he does for a living but
you just got in your car and did your
thing and didn't call for two weeks by
the way never again can you do that if I
put my feelings on the table you get 48
hours and then we're gonna talk about
them and he gets an opportunity to say
hey that's too quick for me
sometimes I need a week and see what I'm
saying now y'all are starting to say
your needs out loud and you're starting
to be honest with with each other and
you're practicing it and he's gonna need
a lot of practice because this is new
for him fair
there and so part of you knowing that
I'm going after a single 53 year old guy
who's never been married never been a
long-term relationship is
going to do things a little unorthodox
or he's going to have some skills to
learn or he's going to have to learn the
new protocols right of how people you
grew up in a world where there was text
messages he grew up in a world where
there were carrier pigeons right very
different planets
I mean I and I'm completely willing to
work on that I've got
I've got the learning curve myself of
the only relationships I've ever been in
our bad ones you know we we each have
our own learning curves as I expect if I
expect for him to work on mine
yes all of hey all of us have learning
curves begin new relationships whether
we're going to work at a new at a new
job whether we have a new kid whether we
are
married and we have or did I the dynamic
of our relationship has changed after
three years or five years or seven years
or 20 years
we all have to quote unquote work on
ourselves and work on our relationship
all the time that's the beauty of it
it's when you start trying to plant
seeds
to feed yourself in an apocalyptic
winter it could go wrong or he might
just be saying yes because don't do that
if you find out six months from now he
just said yes because he was too
insecure to say no and he never liked
you never wanted to kiss you never
wanted to hold your hand in the movie or
whatever
he just did it to go along with it
because he was too nervous to say no
that would be devastating and
heartbreaking
and it will still be better
than if you go into this relationship
you put yourself out there you follow
back up and say hey dingbat I haven't
heard from you in two weeks I put my
heart on the line what are you doing
and he says I'm all in
still worth it
is that fair yeah he is no no no you
you're worth it I don't care about him
he didn't even call you back
okay you're worth it
even if he even if he tells you no
you were honest with you you were brave
for you you were vulnerable on behalf of
you
that's the good stuff in life even when
it doesn't work out
cool
cool here's your homework assignment
call them today and say we're meeting in
person don't let him off the hook with a
phone call
set up a time to meet in person in the
next 24-48 hours
and then you
don't go there with your head down say I
told you I liked you two weeks ago I
haven't heard anything from you
you're gonna have to talk about your
feelings like that don't sing to him he
might think that's weird
cool I mean I was that theater kid I
could sing for him right I know you
could yeah that hey that
I would probably be freaked out a little
bit by that but hey you know what Erica
you do you you like go for it he needs
to know what he's getting into so if you
can burst into song at any moment who
knows but
sit down and be honest with him sit down
and say hey
where are you
where are we
and by the way if you're married been
married a long time my wife and I 20
years of summer we just had this
conversation where are you where are you
had one of the greatest Summers ever and
then we're in the halfway through the
fall and it's already getting hard
how do we get back on track how do we
control delete and start again
and yes it's exhausting yes it's
frustrating and yes it is reality
let's get back on the wagon and start
again
let's go again Erica have a conversation
and you gotta report back you gotta let
me know what he says
I can't wait to hear we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right as you wrap up today's show
with the song lyrics of the day brought
to you by Kelly herself from the great
Carly Rae Jepsen
Carly Rae Jepsen
maybe the greatest name ever
songs called Call Me Maybe and it goes
like this
I threw a wish in the well don't ask me
I'll never tell I look to you as it fell
and now you're in my way I trade my soul
for a wish pennies and dimes for a kiss
I wasn't looking for this but now you're
in my way you s your stair was holding
ripped jeans skin was showing hot not
wind was blowing
where you think you're going baby it's
gross hey I just met you and this is
crazy but here's my number so call me
maybe
get it Erica we'll see you soon